up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about
why i need that but before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
okay let's let's get started
why i need men
there are a million things that i hate
doing and 99
of them are things that most men know
how to do i'm going to give you an
example
one time i got a flat tire and this was
when i was a teenager and loki i was
somewhere that i was not supposed to be
so i could not call my dad which would
have been my first reaction
if i wasn't like doing something i
wasn't supposed to be on um
and so what i did was i ended up calling
the police because it was kind of late
and i wanted to see if they would
you know sit with me and i figured like
they might know how to change the tire
and that night i got my tire changed
what
i'm smart i needed to find someone it
actually was a woman i will say
but in general more men i would say that
women know how to change tires
on top of that i do not know how to fix
my car
my dad fixes it for me every single time
or my brothers and every time they get
in my car
they complain um they say something's
wrong with it
yeah um okay on top of that
another thing that i really don't like
doing or i want
or i don't want to learn yard work
not my thing um i've never mowed the
lawn in my leg my brother's always said
that and the funny thing is my other
brother
is allergic to grass and they still had
him do it
they still had him do it
kind of funny um some would say wrong
some would say wrong others
would say that
i just need men that's it uh okay
biggest thing though
i don't know how to fix anything do you
know how much
when i lived by myself do you wanna know
how much less money i would spend
if i just could fix things but i
wouldn't know how so i would just like
buy
buy things i'll give you an example my
life
um that i bought for my youtube channel
it was like flickering and stuff and i
don't know why so if i was looking by
myself
i would have just bought a new light i
wouldn't know what to do with it how to
fix it but my little brother
came in and did so i don't know what he
did to it all i know is that the light
was fixed and it wasn't like
flickering or buzzing um
before that so basically i'm not saying
as a woman you can't learn those things
because you definitely can
my point is that i don't want to i
genuinely don't want to
um i'd like men to learn that stuff for
me or let me hire them
preferably i think my dad would prefer
the second one because typically i go to
him
or my brothers but
um yeah so let me know in the comments
if you think that we need that or not
because personally
i do um oh my gosh i didn't even add in
plumbing or electric or any of that
stuff
i don't know how to do it and i don't
even want to learn
okay so anyways don't forget to
subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily
videos and i will talk to you guys next
time